Pixar's beautiful new dev the dead
animation Coco is full of Easter eggs
including teasers - Incredibles - Toy
Story and Finding Nemo yippie Kay movie
lovers it's Jan here and today I'm going
to run through all the Pixar Easter eggs
in cocoa some cool cameos you might have
missed plus I'm explaining how cocoa
fits into the Pixar theory and I'm
starting a new Disney Funko pop giveaway
on this video to enter make sure you're
a subscriber and leave a comment about
Coco towards the start of the movie
where Miguel runs through the streets of
his hometown if you look very carefully
you'll notice some Pixar themed pinatas
on sale including Woody and Buzz
Lightyear from the Toy Story movies and
Mike from monsters Inc which is
especially fitting as Coco director Lee
Unkrich was also a director on two of
the Toy Story movies and monsters Inc
the Pizza Planet truck made its first
appearance back in 1995 in the very
first Toy Story movie and if you love
spotting Pixar's Easter Egg regular pop
up in their films then you'll be glad to
see it in cocoa as it drives past
Miguel's house playing music Gong music
by the way Pete's Planet truck is
actually written in Spanish on this
truck because according to director Lee
Unkrich
the idea is that there's a Pizza Planet
franchise in Mexico continuing the Toy
Story theme one of the performers at a
talent contest in the land of the Dead
is wearing a skull t-shirt just like sid
wore in the first and third Toy Story
movies also in the land of the dead
you'll find the luxo ball on a table in
the background when Dante and Frida
Kahlo's monkey race around her workshop
the luxo ball appeared in Pixar's very
first short film look so junior together
with two desk lamps one of which is
still used in Pixar's logo and the Lucha
Libre stand in Miguel's hometown has
numerous wrestling masks on sale one of
which has the same color design as a
luxo ball as well as its star fans of
Finding Nemo and its sequel should keep
their eyes open for the curious little
clownfish and his dad who pop up in a
couple of places first for a Nemo Marlin
and Dory figures on the LME his table in
the town and I'm wondering if these
figures could also be destiny from
finding Dory and if these could be Remi
from ratatouille by the way there's also
a little sculpture of the Coco character
Pepita here who turns up
in the land of the dead and sneakily
hidden among the marigolds on the Rivera
families are frienda there's another
nemo he's really hard to see as his
color blends in with the flowers but now
you know where he is you should be able
to spot him the a113 Easter egg which
has appeared in every single Pixar movie
to date can be found on the door of the
bureau family grievances in the land of
the dead the appearance of a113 in
Pixar's films is an homage to the
classroom at California Institute of the
Arts where many of Pixar's animators
studied six arts films always include
Easter eggs for their next movie which
in the case of cocoa means Incredibles -
in the land of the dead when we gala
nectar are on their way to the talent
contest you need to look very carefully
as down one of the streets that are hard
to spot Incredibles poster you can see
it when someone sets off a firework
which lights of the wall of the building
where the poster is Popo includes
numerous cameos by icons of mexican
culture and history in the land of the
dead there's a funny moment in the queue
to get into an ester that accrues party
where the bouncer gets a selfie of his
disembodied skull taken with El Santo El
Santo was a legendary figure in Lucha
Libre for Mexican professional wrestling
and was known as el in mascot of La
Plata because of the silver mask you can
see him wearing to the party in cocoa
the famous Mexican film stars jorge
negrete and pedro infante there also
appear at Delacruz party in fact the
character of an asterick ruse was
actually partly inspired by pedro
infante mexico's renowned comic film
actor Cantinflas appears later during a
group sing song with de la cruz also in
the group is the famed Mexican
revolutionary Emiliano Zapata and the
influential Mexican actress and singer
maria felix the orchestra conductor at
the big concert towards the end of the
movie is an awed by Pixar's animators to
Michael Giacchino who composed the score
for Coco
the concerts conductor was a bowtie and
top hat and his look reminded me of
photos like this one of jerky know in
real life Frida Kahlo was a hugely
important Mexican artist and in Coco she
plays a suitably significant and
artistic role during Miguel's journey in
the land of the dead
scattered around Carlos workshop in the
film a references to some of her real
paintings including her self-portraits
and still life works with watermelons
and coconuts the Spanish word for which
just happens to be Coco and Freda Sally
Barry hey monkey and our affinity with
Miguel's dog Dante reflect the fact that
in real life Frida Kahlo had several pet
monkeys as well as Xolos or Mexican
hairless dogs as they're also known John
Ratzenberger Pixar's good luck charm has
voiced a character in all of Pixar's
movies so far and in Cocoa he has a
small role as the voice of Juan
orthodontia the promo clip dantos lunch
features a cool cars Easter egg by the
number 95 shoes a little boy is wearing
as Dante zooms past him in the main film
there's also possible Lightning McQueen
Easter egg by the lightning bolt on
Miguel's tee-shirt by the way there are
three different Coco Easter eggs in
Pixar's last movie Cars three and if you
want to find those and all the others
you missed in that movie hit the link at
the end of this video or in the video
description below okay what about the
Pixar theory and how does Coco fit in
for anyone who doesn't know there's a
number of Pixar theories around but the
best-known one is by John Negroni who
suggested a unified timeline for all the
Pixar films in Coco we can see real-life
Pizza Planet trucks driving around and
Pixar characters appearing in pinatas
and a liberty hers which does tie in
with the theory that assured universe
exists the cause Easter eggs though
might be a little problematic as if we
assume Coco takes place in the present
day then there's a potential timeline
problem because according to the grones
Pixar theory the cars movies don't take
place until sometime after 2110 and the
events of wall-e
however the Pixar theory posits that the
Cars characters were at one time driven
by real human owners and when they later
came alive they inherited the
characteristics of their previous human
drivers which means Lightning McQueen
might have had a real human racing
driver who was alive around the time
when Coco takes place hence the cars
Easter eggs so what did you think of
Coco and did you spot any other cool
Easter eggs let me know in the comments
below and don't forget to also subscribe
for your chance to win a Disney Funko
pop congratulations to the winner of my
recent Cars three giveaway whose name is
on screen now if that's you send me a
message via my about page on YouTube and
remember to include your details so I
can send your prize out to you and if
you enjoyed this hit that like
button turn on your notifications to get
my upcoming videos and tap the screen to
watch more of my Disney and Pixar
animation videos including Incredibles 2
and Olaf's frozen adventure thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee Kay weary lovers